Ah ouais ok
Hé au fait
Et tu souviens la dernière fois quand on
regardait Merlin l’enchanteur et que je
trouvais que l’oiseau il avait un nom bizarre
et que tu m’avais dit que c’était le
nom d’un chercheur antique.
Archimède ouais ?
Ben je suis sur sa page Wikipédia là et
le mec il était était à la fois physicien,
astronome, mathématicien, et ingénieurs,
c’est un couteau Suisse de la science quoi
Ouais tu peux même rajouter philosophe, on
est à Syracuse en moins 250, donc ça fait
clairement partie du package.
Mais c’est ouf quand-même, on n’en fait
plus des comme ça.
Euuuuh ouais qu’est-ce que tu veux dire
… parce que dit comme ça ça sonne un peu
réac’ là.
Non mais je veux dire c’est que évidemment
on a toujours des scientifiques aujourd’hui
mais en général ils sont spécialistes d’un
truc ils sont pas à la fois astronome, mathématicien,
physicien et ingénieur… etc
Ah Ok tu veux parler de la pluridisciplinarité
des chercheurs. Tu sais que c’est un vrai
sujet ça, il y aurait carrément de quoi
faire une vidéo.
Moi je suis chaud.
Ben écoute… on est parti.
Bonjour à tous j’espère que vous allez
bien, on est parti pour un nouvel épisode
des coulisses de la recherche
En matière de sciences on est passé de types
qui sont des espèce d’Iron-man des temps
Antiques à faire avancer 12 domaines de recherches
à la fois, à aujourd’hui des scientifiques
qui deviennent de plus en plus spécialistes
de leur discipline, et même au sein même
de leur discipline ils se sur-spécialisent
dans un truc encore plus niche au point de
paraître carrément bizarre aux yeux des
non-initié
T’aurais un exemple.
Tiens par exemple en 2007, la chercheuse Japonaise
Mayu Yamamoto a gagné un prix Ig Nobel pour
avoir découvert que quand on porte une bouse
de vache à très haute température ça permet
d’en extraire un arôme synthétique de
vanille ! tu regarderas plus jamais les cornetto
de la même façon
Ok… Mais maintenant je me demande comment
elle a eu l’idée initiale de faire porter
une bouse de vache à ébullition mais effectivement
c’est plutôt spécifique comme découverte.
Plutôt oui. Et donc là par exemple cette
chercheuse elle est chimiste et elle s’est
ultra spécialisée dans…
Ben dans les bouse de vaches ?!
Oui si on veut oui. Je pensais plus à la
synthèse chimique des arôme mais bref
Il faut bien se rendre à l’évidence que
aujourd’hui les connaissances scientifiques
se sont incroyablement complexifiée depuis
l’époque d’Archimède et les personnes
qui sont spécialistes de plus d’une discipline
et qui en plus sont de très bons scientifiques,
ben c’est quand-même assez rare. Oui parce
que là je suis pas en train de parler de
guignolo qui auraient passé 3 doctorats en
3 ans sans pondre le moindre article scientifique
ou de ta belle soeur qui a réussi ta double
licence guitare-couture à l’université
de putange-pont-écrepin
*non ! L’ourlet en FA DIESE. On reprend.
UT MAJEUR ! BRODERIE !*
Non là je te parle de gens qui publieraient
régulièrement dans des revues de premier
plan dans des disciplines différentes.
Si on regarde l’une des plus grandes distinctions
qui existe dans le monde des sciences comme
le prix Nobel il n’est presque jamais arrivé
qu’une même personne décroche deux prix
Nobel dans 2 disciplines différentes.
Je dis bien presque jamais parce qu’en fait
c’est arrivée une seule fois et c’est
Marie Curie qui obtient en 1903 le prix Nobel
de physique et en 1911 le prix Nobel de chimie.
Donc en plus d’être la première femme
à recevoir un prix Nobel elle reste la seule
personne au monde à avoir reçu 2 Nobel pour
deux disciplines scientifiques différentes
donc GG Madame Curie.
Ouais mais bon on es d’accord que physique…
chimie… c’est un peu pareil quand-même
non ?
Euuuh là je crois que qu’on va se faire
insulter par tous les physiciens, et tous
les chimistes qui passeront par là.
Ok je suppose qu’on peut pinailler mais
en vrai c’est un peu pareil, d’ailleurs
on a bien des cours de « physique-chimie
» au lycée non ?
Non sérieux il faut que t’arrête sinon
l’espace commentaire ça va devenir une
zone d’essai pour missile nucléaire, donc
je vais enchaîner.
S’il est rare de trouver des grands scientifiques
pluridisciplinaire on peut donc se demander
si on va vers toujours plus d’hyper-spécialisation
ou est-ce qu’on valorise quand-même les
chercheurs qui auraient une approche qui s’appuie
sur plusieurs disciplines ?
Et bien rentrons dans le vif de sujet.
*Générique*
Alors avant toute chose, il faut bien voir
que les chercheurs pluri-disicplinaires, qui
mélangent plusieurs approches scientifique
différentes, ça existe bien, mais je vais
vous montrer que le monde de la recherche
est organisé de telle façon qu’ils parviennent
rarement à faire carrière et à s’insérer
dans le champ scientifique.
Je m’appuie ici sur un article de 2022 écrit
par 4 co-auteurs dans Organization Science
et qu’on pourrait traduire par « Une nouvelle
vision de l'impératif catégorique : gardiens
du temple, maintien des frontières et pénalités
d'évaluation dans la science »
Les auteurs ont travaillé sur des données
italiennes pour essayer de voir comment se
positionnent les chercheurs qui ont une approche
pluridisciplinaire dans le monde académique.
La littérature sur le sujet montrait déjà
que les scientifiques pluridisciplinaires
sont en général pénalisés dans leur avancement
de carrière.
Déjà je comprends pas. Pourquoi c’est
pas plus valorisé au contraire ? ça devrait
plutôt être une bonne chose d’avoir plusieurs
cordes à son arc.
Et ben justement pas vraiment, parce qu’en
général les évaluateurs qui sont importants
pour la publication mais aussi pour les recrutement
ils appartiennent à une seule discipline
et ils ont du mal à se faire une idée des
compétences et de la fiabilité d’un candidat
s’il fait appel à des méthodes qu’ils
ne maîtrisent pas trop.
Ah oui donc si je prends un exemple ça fait
que un chercheur qui ferait à moitié de
la physique quantique et à moitié de la
linguistique ils serait évalué soit par
des physicien, soit par des linguistes et
ils auraient chacun du mal à évaluer la
partie dont il sont pas spécialiste.
Alors oui c’est l’idée, sauf que là
dans ce cas- à moins qu’on découvre que
les particules élémentaires se mettent à
parler espéranto quand elle sont dans un
état intriqué… j’ai du mal à saisir
la pertinence de cette double approche…
Cela dit, ces inquiétudes, qu’on comprends
bien, sur la qualité du travail d’un chercheur
pluridisciplinaire devraient normalement se
dissiper quand on est face à un candidat
sur lequel on a beaucoup d’informations
et qui a un super parcours universitaire.
En gros quelqu’un qui a beaucoup publié
et qui est reconnu par ses pairs dans les
deux disciplines. Et bien justement on observe
précisément l’inverse.
C’est-à-dire ?
Donc l’étude porte sur le recrutement à
un poste de professeur dans une université
italienne et les chercheurs ont passé en
revue les 55 497 candidatures qui ont été
soumises à 174 jurys différents. Et à chaque
fois ce sont des jurys spécifiques à une
discipline.
Et ce qu’on voit pour les chercheurs pluridisciplinaires
c’est que plus ils sont performants, donc
plus ils ont de publication et de citation,
et moins ils sont susceptibles d’être recrutés.
Attend attend.. que je comprenne bien, t’es
en train de me dire que plus un chercheur
est bon, plus il est pénalisé ! ça a pas
de sens.
Et pourtant ce qui ressort très clairement.
Et l’effet il est mastoc parce que la pénalité
appliquée à un candidat pluridisciplinaire
très performant est supérieure de plus de
50 % à celle appliquée à un candidat pluridisciplinaire
peu performant.
Ah ouais c’est ouf ça… mais comment on
explique ça ?!
Alors je vais pas détailler toute l’étude
qui fait une vingtaine de page. Elle est en
libre accès et je mettrais le lien dans la
description, si vous voulez une version plus
digeste, les auteurs ont par la suite écrit
une tribune dans le monde pour alerter sur
ce phénomène. Le titre de la tribune est
assez efficace c’est « Plus un chercheur
pluridisciplinaire est performant, moins il
est susceptible d’être accrédité par
ses pairs »
Evidemment je mettrai aussi la tribune du
monde dans la description.
Bon les chercheurs font quand-même des hypothèses
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi on discrimine
plutôt les bon chercheurs pluridisciplinaires
et ils pensent que c’est pour maintenir
le statu quo de la discipline. Et là tu vas
me demander « Pourquoi recruter un bon chercheur
pluridisciplinaire ça viendrait disrupter
le statu quo des disciplines ? »
Non ce que je comprends pas c’est plutôt
Pourquoi recruter un bon chercheur pluridisciplinaire
ça viendrait disrupter le statu quo des disciplines
?
Ben oui c’est que je t’ai dit que… Bref….
Pour comprendre ça il faut bien comprendre
comment est organisé le monde scientifique,
avec des laboratoires, des facultés, des
départements qui ont chacun des modes de
fonctionnements différents, des équipes
d’évaluateurs différentes, et surtout
des financements bien distincts.
Ah oui je crois que j’ai compris, en fait
les chercheurs pluridisciplinaires c’est
un peu le bordel parce qu’ils sont à cheval
sur deux labos donc on sait jamais vraiment
qui qui doit les financer en plus c’est
plus difficile d’évaluer leur travail s’ils
utilise des méthodes un peu atypique… Ouais
mais ça ça nous explique toujours pas pourquoi
c’est les bons chercheurs qui se font le
plus discriminer.
Justement j’y viens. Ce qu’il faut avoir
en tête c’est que dans le monde universitaire
il y a en fait un tout petit nombre de gens
talentueux et productifs qui vont exercer
une influence disproportionnée sur l’avenir
de leur discipline. Ils peuvent décider notamment
des domaines de recherche prioritaire et de
l’orientation vers de nouvelles approches,
de nouvelles théories ou de nouvelles méthodes.
On peut prendre l’exemple de la sociologie.
La sociologie française actuelle à l’université
ne serait probablement pas la même aujourd’hui
si Bourdieu n’avait pas existé. Il est
le tout premier sociologue à obtenir la médaille
d’or du CNRS, il a été professeur au collège
de France, il a fondé une revue qui est encore
aujourd’hui très prestigieuse, bref, il
a marqué sa discipline.
Du coup pour en revenir au recrutement il
faut bien se mettre dans la tête des jury,
quand ils recrutent un super bon chercheurs,
ils se disent qu’ils sont potentiellement
en train de recruter le nouveau Pierre Bourdieu
de leur discipline, ou à tout le moins quelqu’un
qui va avoir de l’influence dans le champ
scientifique. C’est pour ça que recruter
un chercheur pluridisciplinaire très bon,
ça peut menacer le statu quo des disciplines
parce qu’il va peut-être fusionner des
labos ou des source de financement ou ouvrir
des champ de recherche où les anciens ne
sont pas vraiment compétents. Alors qu’à
l’inverse un collègue pluridisciplinaire
dont le CV n’est pas particulièrement remarquables
il paraît plus inoffensif et il du coup subit
moins la pénalité au moment du recrutement.
Ah ben merde. En fait les mecs ont juste peur
que s’ils recrutent quelqu’un de trop
bon sleur petit département et leur petites
méthodes bien confortable soient bouleversées
par des programmes de recherche nouveaux,
et du coup ils préfèrent torpiller les potentiels
innovateurs. Mais attend ça ça va pas du
tout dans le sens d’une meilleure science
et de meilleures connaissances scientifiques
!
Et non, mais il faut bien avoir en tête que
la science elle est avant tout faite par des
humains qui ne sont pas des purs esprits tournés
vers la vérité mais qu’ils ont eux aussi
des intérêts, des biais et des habitudes
et que ça ben ça influence assez largement
les découvertes scientifiques.
C’est notamment ce que montrait le sociologue
Bruno Latour qui vient malheureusement de
nous quitter ce 9 octobre 2022. Dans un de
ses livres les plus célèbre est La vie de
Laboratoire écrit avec le sociologue des
sciences Steve Woolgar sorti en 1979. Ils
ont fait une étude ethnologique dans un laboratoire
de recherche spécialisé en neuroendocrinologie
et ils montrent justement que la science elle
fonctionne pas du tout comme on peut se représenter
naïvement la « méthode scientifique » avec
des gros guillemets, mais qu’au contraire
les objets d’études scientifiques sont
« socialement construits » dans des laboratoires,
au cours d’interactions humaines. En fait,
comme on vient de le voir, la science elle
s’appuie sur des institutions humaines,
des universités, des laboratoires, qui définissent
elle-même des frontières entre les disciplines,
qui peuvent paraître arbitraire à un œil
extérieur mais qui produisent des effets
sur le type de science qui est produite.
Ça à l’air intéressant ce que raconte
Bruno Latour là, on peut pas développer
un peu plus ?
Oulah t’es ambitieux parce que Bruno Latour
c’est un gros morceau, mais je suis justement
en train de préparer une petite vidéo spéciale
pour essayer d’en parler un peu plus longuement.
Parce qu’il a fait beaucoup de choses dans
sa vie et d’ailleurs, on est en train de
parler de pluridisciplinarités il cumulait
déjà pas mal de casquette : sociologue,
anthropologue, théologien, philosophe des
sciences… et clairement on en reparlera
un autre fois.
Bon Ok, j’attendrai jusquà l’épisode
spécial mais t’a intérêt à le sortir
avant la prochaine décennie.
Conclusion.
Bon tout ça pour dire que la pluridisciplinarité
en science c’est pas si facile que ça à
mettre en place. Outre le fait que dès qu’on
entre dans le supérieur on a de moins en
moins de filières pluridisciplinaires on
voit que les structures et les acteurs de
ses filières ont un intérêt pour leur carrière
à conserver le statut quo et les frontières
entre chaque discipline. Du coup les chercheurs
qui pourrait donner un petit coup de pied
dans la fourmilière se heurtent à un plafond
de verre, et en particulier les chercheurs
les plus brillants et productifs ont du mal
à accéder aux postes qui leur permettrait
d’avoir vraiment de l’influence sur les
trajectoires des projets de recherche.
Des solutions seraient tout de même envisageables
et les auteurs de la tribune proposent par
exemple une diversification du profil des
jury ou de mettre en place une forme de « discrimination
positive » envers les profils pluridisciplinaires.
Je vous laisse lire la tribune du monde pour
plus de détail.
Une question que je me suis moi-même posée
en lisant l’article, c’est si on trouvait
le problème dans les mêmes proportions dans
les sciences humaines et sociales. Parce que,
intuitivement il me semble qu’il y a plus
de pluridisciplinarité au sein des SHS que
dans les autres disciplines, à la fois dans
la manière de les enseigner que dans la diversité
des méthodes qui sont mobilisée. Mais ça,
ce sera le sujet pour la prochaine vidéo.
Cette vidéo des coulisses de la recherche
est maintenant terminée, j’espère qu’elle
vous aura plu. N’hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce vers le haut et surtout à la partager,
c’est super important de partager.
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne SocioloGeek si
c’est pas déjà fait, c’est gratuit et
comme ça vous ne manquerez pas la vidéo
suivante sur la pluridisciplinarité en sciences
humaines, qui sortira très bientôt sur la
chaîne, je vous le promet.
Je vous fais des gros bisous et je vous dit
à très vite. Ciao.